this is a production of Cornell
University
thank you for coming today I'm really
excited to talk to you about what we've
been working on up in Geneva with a
willow and if you get a second please
check out our website we've now coined
the term below pedia and if you have any
further questions after the talk about
willow you can find out some more
information on the website so the energy
and independent security act of 2007
basically stated that we want to try to
reach 36 billion gallons of renewable
fuels by 2022 and currently if you look
over here currently our status of
cellulosic biofuels is pretty minimal
compared to this graph and compared to
other conventional biofuels and those
consist of ethanol from corn and sugar
cane and those are expected to not
increase that much within the next 10
years and actually will eventually
plateau off whereas cellulosic biofuels
are going to increase and they're going
to increase significantly and we need to
start looking at other crops other than
corn and other than sugar cane in order
to reach the goal of 36 billion gallons
by 2022 uh so back in 2005 the USDA in
the D OE conducted a study and they
called the billion tons study and the
point of this study was to determine if
the United States had enough resources
biomass resources in order to replace
thirty percent of petroleum usage by
2030 and that was back in 2005 and they
actually found out that we needed to
produce a billion tons dry tons of
biomass yearly in order to replace that
thirty percent
uh this back in the spring they just put
out an update to the billing time study
and this figure was taken from that and
basically showing that by 2022 we should
be able to produce over that billion ton
mark and if you notice this orange is
energy crops and along with an increase
in pretty much all of these resources
forest land resources logging residues
forest product residues along with the
current agricultural crops that we are
using we're going to have to increase
energy crops in order to reach these
goals and actually to even reach our
billion time limit okay so what are
energy crops there's dedicated energy
crops they're not crops that are going
to be used for food so corn is an
example that's used for food and we also
use it to make ethanol these would be
strictly used for bioenergy some of
these are Miscanthus giganteus and
perennial grasses prairie grasses such
as switchgrass in this picture others
are canary graphs big bluestem these are
there's a bunch of different types of
prairie grasses that could be that have
the potential to be good energy crops
what we're looking for is something that
can produce I amounts of biomass in a
short period of time and these can do it
in addition to the grasses we also have
woody bioenergy crops and included in
this or hybrid poplar and also from
willow this is a picture of Fred right
there Larry's new grad student this is
this image was just taken about a month
ago um and at a trial up in Geneva and
that's about three years growth right
there
okay so we have all these different
types of feed stuffs and the problem is
that multiple universities from all
around the country are working on
different feedstocks studying them for
yield and other custom disease
resistance and other specific traits and
so the Sun grant initiative was set up
by Congress to basically work together
to create a national network where we
can combine all of this research that's
been going on on all these different
crops and all these different trials and
they divided the United States into the
five different regions and and basically
came up with the regional biomass
feedstock partnership and they stood up
centers at each of those regions and for
the Northeast Cornell is that Center
okay and most of their funding is coming
from the Department of Transportation
the USDA and the Department of Energy in
addition to this national network
they're also the bioenergy research
centers that have been set up by the
Department of Energy and those are
located in California up in the Great
Lakes and down in Tennessee so
essentially this figure showing you that
the United States is working on
developing renewable energy and it is
forming some form of a cohesive national
connection and so this is a rather
complex image but what this image is
showing you are the field trials for all
of the feedstock crops throughout the
United States and this is an all of them
this is just a representation of a
decent amount of them the blue stars
represent poplar and you can see that
they're scattered pretty much around the
United States the Upper Midwest the
north
and in the south as well if you notice
the Black Stars are willow and they are
mostly within the Northeast so the idea
is that the feedstocks would be regional
because the ideal growing conditions for
a particular crop are not going to be
all over the United States they're going
to be regions of the United States and
for well oh that would be the Northeast
okay so a little background on Trev
willow uh you can find they are members
of the genus salix in the Sailor kcee
family and are you can find native and
naturalized species throughout the
region along Y period and wetland
habitats along the edges of rivers and
streams and to any clearings edges of
railroads and roadsides they are a
pioneer species they are dioecious which
has so they're obligate outcrossing and
they've maintained high levels of
genetic diversity as a result of that
many species can hybridize and they have
a short generation time and they
propagate clonally which is rather
adventitious from a breeding perspective
in addition I would do want to talk
about a little bit about the cultivation
history of the cultivation of shrub
willow in the United States actually
started out for basket making and this
particular species salix purpurea was
brought over from Europe for the purpose
of making baskets and probably in the
mid-nineteen early 1900s the basket make
it base basket making industry for with
willow kind of declined and so a lot of
these fields of willow salix purpurea
were abandoned and now salix / Korea has
naturalized throughout the region and
you can find it in WoW
tats similar to this picture right here
so for our purposes we want to cultivate
willow what we want to cultivate it for
a bioenergy crop and so we have to go to
an unnatural scenting to a field setting
and in order to do this we have to
prepare sites and basically kill any
weeds with herbicide such as roundup and
then also apply pre-emergence before we
actually plant and this image here is an
image of our zone tillage which is we
first set this up this year we're trying
some tillage and comparing it against
conventional tillage conventional
tillage until the whole field whereas in
this case you're only telling the rows
where the willow get will get planted
and this is a great image to see that we
plant in double rows okay uh so we plant
with unrooted cuttings uh you take
willow whips and they are fed into a
cutter head they're cut to about 30
centimeters pushed into the ground and
then these packer wheels pack the dirt
back around that willow cutting and
there's an example of some of the
cuttings that we would plant gives you
an idea of how the size of the tub and
there it is in the ground and then by
the end of the summer so saving plants
in May or June are the end of the summer
there look like that and that's not very
big they dedicate most of their energy
to root production in the first year so
they don't grow very well the first year
so that's why weed control is extremely
important these guys can get easily get
overgrown by weeds if the weed
management isn't taking care of that
first year that winter the plants are
copies back cut back to the ground and
then in the spring Hillary sprout and
that's the receiver
spring after your year gross we're here
and then three years after coppice we
will then cut the willow ok we will
essentially harvest the willow and this
cycle can continue for about seven years
roughly and you can harvest own about a
three or four year rotation some people
can even do a two year rotation so it
just depends how often you want to
harvest and the the seven-year harvest
cycle this limitation does not mainly
due to growth of the willow willow will
continue to grow vigorously but the
stools get too large and it's harder to
get equipment through so we have to
actually it's time to pull out the
stools and replant ok so for harvesters
we actually have quite a few different
harvesters that you could work with
depending upon your needs and practices
um there's these guys on either side
here which are rather large they're
heavy but they're great because they can
cut the two double rows those double
rows at the same time and but they do
use up quite a bit of energy and they
are very heavy so for larger field
trials they'd be great but for smaller
field right field trials it might be
rather inefficient so we've um have this
it's a these are modified forage
harvesters and this one can do one row
at a time it's a little bit smaller it
can be attached to the back of a tractor
and it's easier to get through for
smaller trials and it'd probably be a
little bit more energy efficient and
then we also have the option of a bio
baylor so you can actually bail the
willow and also you can harvest the
whole stems so if you wanted to harvest
for planting stock since we plant those
will ellipse you don't want to actually
chip the biomass you want to keep those
willow as Holt stems so those are some
options for harvesting so what do we do
after we harvest the biomass and we have
a bunch of wood chips
there's multiple options for biomass
conversion there's basically two main
types of conversion you've got
thermochemical and you have biochemical
thermochemical conversion includes basic
combustion which is just burning the
biomass or co-firing it with coal is
another option I'm going to outproduce
on the emissions for the coal plants you
can densify the willow into pallets and
four cats and then burn via combustion
and then you can also undergo further
processing through gasification or
pyrolysis this will producing ass
biochar and then you can go through
biochemical conversion which is
essentially accessing the polysaccharide
component of the biomass converting it
into monosaccharides into sugars and
then fermenting those into ethanol or
butanol and you can also use this to
make other bio products for us there's
multiple phenotypic traits that we are
interested in looking at up first and
foremost is yield we want to produce a
heavy produce a big producing crop
that's our product the biomass is our
product so we want a lot of it and we
want to be able to do it cheaply and one
issue that we do have are some pests and
diseases insect damage and fungal
pathogens can have a significant impact
on yield so we need to make sure that we
are as we're breeding for high-yielding
lilla clones that we are also
maintaining some level of pest
resistance and disease tolerance this is
an image of willow rust that can have a
significant impact on yield and in
addition to that we are also looking at
woody biomass traits density and
Composition in particular and this is
going to really help evaluate the
quality of the biomass and also allow us
to identify what genotypes can be
marketed for the
different types of conversion processes
sister mo chemical or the biochemical so
again the main goal is high yield and
that's mainly been captured through
hybrid vigor and this diagram just shows
you a nice using a nice idea of the
species that we've worked with and the
diversity that we've maintained within
the breeding program and also the
hybrids that do work and the ones that
actually don't cross very well the
dotted lines are basically no seeds of
being produced through those we do work
with about 20 to 30 different species
with within the breeding program so it
is a larger array of species than a
normal agricultural crop that might have
two or three species okay so we're going
to talk about bio mass composition today
that's the main focus of my talk and
wouldn't buy my straits and just a quick
review that biomass is essentially the
reflection of a syllable chemistry and
the cell wall in in a woody stem mainly
consists of three main polymers
cellulose Hemi cellulose is such as glue
caranas Island and lignin this image
here is actually a primary cell wall so
you do have pectin in there as well
along with the cellulose microfibrils
and there's no lignin in this cell wall
because it hasn't gotten and it hasn't
penetrated in and the pectin hasn't been
dissolved and the lignin hasn't taken
over but it still gives you a pretty
good idea on how complex the cell wall
is and the cell walls designed for
structural integrity so and barriers to
pathogens for the plaint so it's
actually not easily broken down
very recalcitrant and to access those
polysaccharides is not an easy process
and especially for the biochemical
conversion side of things we need to
understand a little bit more how to
break down the cell wall and so there's
been a lot of work being done on that
but my focus is more on composition can
we affect impacts like changing the
composition can we actually impact
conversion and improve the conversion
process or improve the pretreatment
process and access those polysaccharides
better so but first we actually have to
be able to characterize the biomass in a
rather efficient way the wood
composition originally traditionally
wood composition is characterized by old
wet chemical methods these are based off
of the tapping methods technical
applications of the pulp and paper
industry and also the newer methods by
NREL standard biomass analytical
procedures and these require harsh
chemicals you're using a lot of
equipment you were boiling Tolley mean
boiling ethanol boiling sulfuric acid
basically to pull out the
polysaccharides separate out the lignin
and be able to actually quantify those
components within the wood and it's
rather time-consuming and so the newer
processes that were looking at our
instrumental methods actually developing
kemah metric models to determine
composition although we do need the
traditional wet chemistry analysis in
order to calibrate any of the newer
models that we are trying to develop uh
so I'm going to talk a little bit about
near-ir and TGA this image over here is
and it's an IR spectrophotometer which I
will actually be starting to
some samples on within the near future I
have done some work on developing
near-ir models d and then I've also done
some work with this instrument over here
which is called a thermogravimetric
analyzer ah the advantage of the
spectroscopic techniques the IRA and the
near-ir is that this is a
non-destructive method essentially just
grind down the biomass and you can
analyze it with total reflectance and
then you're not losing any of your bio
mess thermogravimetric analyzers
actually burning the sample so you do
end up losing it in the process and it
does take a little bit longer then the
ir and nir models this is a image of a
thermogram of a sample that was put
through the TGA and what i want to point
out here are the two curves you have a
black curve which is essentially weight
loss with respect to temperature and
then you have the derivative of that
curve which is the blue line the
thermogram of met the thermogravimetric
analyzer works pretty it's pretty
straightforward it actually just burns
the sample as I waited now this
classically has been used to resolve
polymeric mixtures as long as each
individual polymer within the mixture
has a different decompositional
temperature as long as they combust at
different temperatures you can resolve
them and essentially would is a mixture
of polymers so that's how this works ah
you start of this dotted line up here
right here represents water loss from
the sample and then as you increase in
temperature you will start to combust
Hemi cellulose
and then as you continue you'll start to
combust cellulose and stereos the
crystalline cellulose peak is right at
300 degrees so crystal and cellulose
firms exactly at 300 degrees Celsius and
then following that you will lose a
little bit more cellulose and you'll
start getting into lignin combustion now
this is done in complete air if we were
doing this in a deoxygenated environment
that would be pyrolysis and you wouldn't
get complete combustion of these three
components and you'd end up with char at
the end okay the other advantage of
doing the thermal carbo metric analysis
is that there's been a lot of work of
using this to study the kinetics of wood
and looking at thermal conversion
thermochemical conversion processes and
understanding a little bit more about
the thermal decomposition of biomass so
I have developed three models one for
cellulose hemicellulose and lignin based
off of using wet chemical data and
correlating that to the results from the
TGA so the x axis is the true value %
cellular is determined by wet chemistry
and the y axis is the predicted value
the percent cellular is determined by
the TGA and ideally you want if one drew
one curve on this so you really want x
equals y equals x so you really would
like to see an r-squared of one but
that's not going to ever be the case and
so these were the best models that I
could come up with for cellulose in our
square root of point 744 Hemi cellulose
and r square root of point eight six and
four lignin and r square 2.76 so
essentially this is a pretty good model
and we can use it to phenotype a large
number of samples in addition to the TGA
I want to talk a little bit about the
near I
this is a spectra of three willow
samples three different willow samples
you can tell it's a rather complex
spectra it's not you're not going to be
able to observe specific Peaks you're
actually observing the overtones of bond
of absorbances of bonds not the actual
absorbance of the fonts like you would
in infrared the advantage of nir over
infrared is that you don't have to deal
with too much water absorption you do
over on this end there's a little bit of
water absorption coming in over here but
it's not as much of a problem as doing
ir spectroscopy so this really requires
a very good camera metric model to
resolve the spectra and actually
identify what changes in the spectra are
correlating to changes in composition so
I started working on this a couple years
ago and the issue is that the nir needs
a lot of larger calibration set than the
TGA does so a lot more samples that have
been characterized so it does take a
little bit more time this graph over
here is predicted versus truce or
predicted is on the x-axis trues on the
note Rouge on the x-axis predicted is on
the y axis and this one is cellulose the
green represents barked samples so just
the bark has been stripped off of the
stem the orange is the straight biomass
so that's the whole stem wood and bark
and then the blue is just the wood so
the bark was removed and it's just the
wood and these purple samples which are
only in lignin model um or magenta I'm
not sure what you want to call that our
samples from trial in Saskatchewan and
they have lower lignin content
and by any of the biomass samples from
child's around here so I threw them into
the models to try to make the model a
little bit better so the models so far
can distinguish these different tissue
types which is great but they're having
a harder time distinguishing genotypes
from each other so we need to work on
these models better we need to make them
better and the only way to do that is to
increase the calibration set increase
the amount of samples that the known
samples that your sterling into the data
set and that's the only way that we're
going to improve the model but in the
meantime we're doing pretty good we've
got our Squared's above ninety percent
so that's a pretty good number but we
need to be able to resolve this better
so for now I'm still using the TGA to
phenotype willow samples and that's it
I'm not using the nir yet so I put up
this figure I wanted to show you um some
of the things that we've been doing
utilizing the TGA I have been analyzing
pretty much all of the samples that are
coming out of all the individuals that
are coming out of our trials but in this
particular trial the same individuals
were planted at two contrasting sites
the idea was to start to begin to look
at some gye interactions how does the
environment impact composition and this
top figure is cellulose and cellulose
based off of the stats was significantly
different by sight and the interaction
between clown and site was
government okay so basically what that
was saying is that at this site
belleville the green the lighter green
you will have higher cellular's content
than at the other site at the tully site
uh Hemi cellulose did not change that
much between the two sides and lignin
was cloned or variety in site-specific
so the only two varieties that had
significantly higher ligand at the tully
location are these two are these two
right here and they are both um esta bem
announced by s my Vienna hi rose so
there still needs to be so work to us
begin to identify what is the actual
environmental component that's impacting
these we have done soil analysis but we
haven't done an in-depth enough work to
actually figure out what is at what's
actually regulating these traits and
have carbon allocation to the cell wall
is changing based on those environmental
conditions we've also looked at ash
content so the great thing about the TGA
is that after everything burns whatever
is left over is ash so I don't have to
do another step to determine ash content
so ash can be an issue because from a
consumer perspective people who have
wood stoves or pellet stoves they don't
want to be cleaning out as much ash so
lower ash is going to be better for the
market also for gasification ash can
cause clinking and which is can actually
damage the equipment so ideally you want
low ash and you want it to be maintained
over different environmental conditions
depending upon where your field trials
are you want to have low ash and you can
clearly see that certain varieties have
significantly higher ash at the
bellville site versus the tele site
whereas others are maintaining low ash
at both
like these two espurr permeate clowns so
in addition I've also looked at wood
density and wood density was also also
significantly different between the two
sites it was higher at tully compared to
belleville and there's been some
research on looking at wood density and
growth rates and there's a theory out
there that higher wood densities
associated with a lower growth rate and
we did find higher yield of these
varieties at the bellville site lower
yield at the telly side so that would
make a little sense however there's no
correlation between yield and density
and there's no correlation with you and
any of the biomass trees yield was only
correlated with pests and insect damage
so there needs to be again more research
which leads me to here we've also been
doing some sugar release so again we
thought that by altering lignin content
lowering link lignin content increasing
the polysaccharide component of the
biomass that you can increase the sugar
that you produced for the sugared
released for fermentation so this is an
image of sugar release from untreated
biomass so it hasn't gone through that
pretreatment process of breaking apart
of the cell wall it's just basic ground
up biomass and we threw it into some an
enzyme mix to break down the sugars
break down the polysaccharides into
sugars to see what we could get and with
these varieties we are getting a rather
wide range in sugar release however none
of this correlated to biomass
composition so my next slide so there
are some correlations the first one the
most important one I say is cellular
services lignin so there
is some collinearity between biomass
components because as you increase the
content of one you're going to lower the
content they have the other and vice
versa so it's nice to see that we can
find this trend of is this negative
relationship between cellulose and
lignin however this can be site
dependent so certain trials you can't
find this trend you can't find this
correlation but other trials you can so
we still don't know what's controlling
what they're still needs to be some more
work we've also found that sugar yield
is correlated to density it actually has
a positive relationship with density and
there's a question of whether there's a
relationship between cellulose and
density I've seen it in some trials but
haven't seen it in others and as you
increase that crystal and cellular stew
inside the cell wall that's going to
impact density so there's a question of
whether or not a higher cellulose
content is correlated with density but
we're not seeing that here so and we're
not seeing a relationship between
cellulose and sugar yield so it
basically it's just what this basically
is saying that we have a lot more that
we need to learn about the biomass and
how it's actually relating to sugar
release how the environment is impacting
composition and that may be reducing
lignin content increasing the
polysaccharide content does not have an
effect on sugar yield
sir really we need to start
understanding the genetic component of
the side of things and we've done all
this meat these phenotypic measurements
and now it's time to start understanding
the genotype and to start I worked on I
worked on this family as second instance
is my Vienna the progeny of his family's
this was a cross between two parents and
we produce progeny and that progeny we
used in a study for real-time pcr and I
collected to tissue types the shoot apex
tissue and the young stub tissue with
the idea that I would be capturing
primary cell wall development as well as
secondary cell wall development and I
wanted to look at particular genes
associated with cell wall development
this is the phenyl propionate metabolism
pathway which leads to the production of
the mono lignoss the subunits for
producing lignin p camaro alcohol Cano
Farrell alcohol and snapple alcohol I
looked at about three different genes
involved in this pathway in addition to
I'm not going to get too far into this
because it's a little bit too
complicated in addition to the lignin I
was also interested in looking at the
polysaccharides that are being produced
into this in the cell wall and um in
particular cellulose synthesis UDP
glucose dehydrogenase and the multitude
of glycosyltransferases that are
involved in the production of the Hemi
cellulose woo caranas Island and also
pectin so there's hundreds of genes that
are involved with the production of
polysaccharides with
the cell wall and I can't go through
them all but so I'm going to focus in on
to UDP glucose dehydrogenase and
cellulose synthase for this top figure
is gene expression within the apex
tissue from the to panic clowns sx 61
and s x64 and there's six progeny so the
dark green and the light green are the
parents and then the in-between green
are the progeny so the top is the apex
this the next figure is the stem the
lower part of the stem that I looked at
and then this last figure on the bottom
is the relationship the gene expression
between the two tissue types and with
both of these genes you can see that the
apex has lower gene expression compared
to the stem and so basically implying
that these are probably involved with
secondary cell wall metabolism so these
are correlations of these probe the gene
expression of those two genes with
percent polysaccharide content in the
biomass in mature biomass and percent
lignin content as well and if you notice
UDP glucose dehydrogenase gene
expression has a negative relationship
with polysaccharide content and has a
positive relationship with lignin
whereas with cellulose as expected
you've got a positive relationship with
cellulose content and negative
like men so this is a little interesting
question here and there's been a little
bit of work I've done on this by Deborah
Deborah samick at the USDA and
University of Minnesota a collaborative
effort between the two of them to
actually lower lignin content in alfalfa
and in order to do that they lower the
gene expression of they actually down
regulated UDP glucose dehydrogenase and
what ended up happening was they saw the
exact opposite so basically saying that
as you pull UDP glucose dehydrogenase
away from cellulose what you end up
doing is increasing lignin not lowering
it so it's kind of counterintuitive that
make sense
um okay so analyzing this stuff one gene
at a time can be rather difficult so we
need to start looking at this on a
bigger level on the genome level on the
transcriptome level and even though
we've started to identify candidate
structural genes we need to do a little
bit more and so that's where it comes
into the sequencing of the genome and
also looking at transcriptome data and
eventually leading into whole genome
selection and we started to sequence the
genome who's working with salix purpurea
with the clone ID 9406 and we do have
some preliminary data we've done some
454 and we've done some aluminum and we
are waiting on a high seek run we still
haven't gotten the results from that one
so our assembly so far is rather it's
not it's okay it could be better and
then we also have to back libraries that
we've created a random to your library
from Lucy June and then a traditional
restriction enzyme library from coogi
Clemson University genomic Institute and
we've done with our initial assembly
willow we've done some comparisons to P
the P trichocarpa genome and they do
have a similar similar size genome and
we do see a sixty-five percent of the
Paycheck of Gina p trichocarpa geno
align to that draft assembly and the
sequence identity between the coding and
the non-coding regions was about eighty
eight percent so that's pretty good in
addition to that we've done some
transcriptome sequencing we've looked at
eight we have eight different tissue
libraries we collected shoot tips RNA
from shoot tips RNA from leaves that
were pooled from three different
collection times we did a midday
collection we did a nighttime collection
and we also collected drought stress
leaves and then we've also looked at
two different sections of the stem we
looked at the node in the internode we
have collected roots and we've also
looked at the female cat came because
9406 is a female so we looked at the
transcripts in that as well and we've
also done some work with those two
parents that I used that were used in
the real-time essays that cross that I
did the a second answer is my van is
that there's two parents we've also done
some work with the stem and the shoot
tip these two are both tetraploid so
it'd be interesting to see the
transcripts that come out of that so
aarani seek assembly for here's the
results for the S purpurea um sequence
assembly for the transcripts and if you
can see our average read length was
about 394 base pairs and based off of
that 80.5 percent of the poplar
transcripts have at least half of their
length along to the willow transcripts
and the sequence identity between those
two card in regions between salix
purpurea and p trichocarpa is ninety-two
percent and remember the genomic was
eighty eight percent in addition at JC
VI they've been kind enough to create a
gbrowse for us so we can now start
looking at jeans with in Willow and
essentially using poplar as a reference
genome and doing a de novo trend in the
de novo transcript assembly and the nice
thing is that here's a contact a willow
can take some of these contacts are
actually spanning full genes which is
fantastic and so we can not only start
characterizing gene families but we can
also start looking at some expression
profiles
and here is the sale of cellulose
synthase gene family from the salix
purpurea and I compared gene expression
in the shoe tip and the step stem
internode and I boxed these individual
these genes that are boxed are those
involved in secondary cell wall
metabolism and as you can see their gene
expression is higher in the stem
compared to the shoot tip uh so
essentially we've done a ton of
phenotypic measurements and we're
improving our methods for phenotypic
phenotyping a lot of these traits and
but we need to do more and basically
what it comes down to is that we need to
characterize the phenotype and the
genotype better and we'll be able to do
that through using mapping populations
and also doing some g by g via GPS which
we've just started to do Fred's been
working on that and we'll be able to
start doing some snip analysis and
eventually leading to full genome
selection so we can actually start in
breeding for particular woody biomass
traits which is eventually where we want
to go and my acknowledgments again I
want to thank very smart for being my
mentor for the past six years and
providing me with financial assistance
and Tim Vulcan Larry abrahamson at SUNY
ESF who are involved with the developing
and create getting the willow breeding
program going will the bullet program I
arts to Panama CH at ESF along with
Larry Walker and Stefan party down at
the Viera have been instrumental in the
will determining the competition for
willow biomass and getting those models
going and then all of the people
involved with the wheel of genomics
at the craig Venter institute and at JDI
and then Martin golf ranae for the
microscopy work he helped me with a lot
of that and then my funding over the
years my current
in the future incineration right
no yeah you know and I've gone back in
the literature to actually try to find
people who've done work on actually
characterizing ash in different biomass
feedstocks and that's been rather hard
but so it should be done yeah because
different components will impact things
differently so everything you need to
look at that more and barca will happen
mortgaging pet to more bark than him or
ash so we do not
yeah would you consider possible
transgenic approaches to improve food
quality or is that too difficult because
of its a naturalized species in the
bigger guys you know actually we there
is no genetic transformation method for
below we cannot do it yet so there's
been a lot of work dedicated to that
getting it into tissue culture and
difficult but you can do it that's
possible but you can't regenerate so
they've had a hard time on that end
getting me Phoenix I mean you can do the
transformation on a callous I guess but
you can't get it but there's still some
work being done on that so maybe
something you think that since they're
so easy to prove they're so easy to root
that you could give it to regenerate
that faithfully book no I mean people
have tried different concentrations
different changing normal ratios
oh dear there were three right there sir
how many years
yeah so that's probably you aren't the
height yeah so
yeah yeah 20 to 25 feet so let's say hi
and then as far as the violence we can
get above 10 10 to 14 dry times per
so if you harvest after the third here
you can eat that kind of appeal oh yeah
no we're getting for you so the next
cycle of harvest you'll get more so the
first year you get that 10 to 14 but the
second cycle you're going to get what
twenty percent increase environments
direction then I don't think we know
beyond that don't think we've gone past
the second rotation
yeah okay well we've actually most of
the varieties that we've patented for
yield our trip boys
yeah so that so that initial family that
I did the real-time work on we didn't
know where tetraploid until afterwards
so we're interested in looking at that
but from a genomic standpoint and we
really want to stick with the diploid
Oh
the ball carrier is there I don't think
it really matters the larger the stem
you're going to have a harder time
harvesting um but I mean the harvesters
you can handle you three diameter stems
no problem at the base but you know we
did have this question of whether or not
reducing the bark to wood ratio by
increasing stem diameter with that
reduce lignin content or without reduce
ash content we haven't done the work to
figure that out yet so but as far as
stem diameter gums I don't I mean we
have varieties that have very small
diameter stems but lots of them and then
we also have varieties that have just a
few stems that are very large and so and
they've all been some of those have been
patented as well so they're still
producing high yield regardless of stem
diameter
you mean a different crops yeah um yeah
it's so the grasses have a little bit
different composition than a hard one
booth but you basically in general all
in the cellulose requirements
difficult but I don't really know if
there's been differences in
recalcitrance between different country
breakfast vs for good apartments so
there hasn't been like
not really yes
I think in general we're talking about
just all the inside of those
environments just what what species or
what types it will produce five year old
not so much it's been more if you've
been on okay what kinds of microbes and
we get to break down stuff better
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu